crisis is the great revealer right when
there's a crisis truth just isn't just
it's there stark for everyone to see
immediately we could tell who had the
good cultures who at the wheat cultures
who are the good leaders who had the
weak leaders like instantaneously right
um
and
unfortunately
um even though they struggled
a lot of the finite-minded companies
have not adjusted
um you could tell who were finite-minded
and infinite-minded from the get-go the
finite-minded panicked right that was
their reaction panic
because finite-minded leaders
fear uncertainty and hate surprises
which is why they like short time frames
because you can exert more control over
a quarter than you can over five years
right i can actually make a pretty
decent prediction over a quarter and
have control of that maybe even a year
five years i got nothing right
whereas the infinite minded leaders they
embrace uncertainty and think surprise
is simply opportunity waiting to happen
because they find creativity in
uncertainty
and unfortunately the old guard the
companies that you know i have publicly
railed against who are extremely finite
minded i don't think they changed much i
think they reacted the way they used to
react i think they went to extreme cost
cutting i don't necessarily think that
they did it in a noble way they didn't
treat people with dignity
many of them saw covet as an opportunity
we know some of those scandals right
they took in ppp money
uh
when their numbers were fine
et cetera et cetera et cetera we saw it
happen they maintained a finite mindset
even while others were struggling there
was no sense of how do we help
everyone
that was how do we help ourselves there
is a new breed of company that is
emerging
that understands the infinite game and
is challenging the old way of doing
business there's a new breed of leader
it's airbnb i count as one of them sweet
green is another one you know these
young
these young companies with these young
forward thinking leaders they're asking
these questions and they they don't like
the way
wall street exerts uncomfortable and
unbalanced
pressure
on on public companies to do the wrong
thing
very often
more companies are staying private for
longer
so they can maintain an infinite
mindedness
and there is a few emerging leaders that
are i think are becoming the new the new
heroes of business you know jack welch
was a really bad example of what we
should do in business and yet he was the
hero of the 80s and 90s well think about
the 80s and 90s they would boom years
like finite-mindedness like it was like
was king
turns out you know
when you don't have a booming economy in
glo and world peace it's much harder
so i i'm bullish that there's a new
breed of of executive a new kind of
metric a new kind of culture
where we have a return to people who
want to give their lives to a company as
opposed to a year a year a year a year a
year which is simply a reaction to to
not feeling like i want to stay here for
the rest of my life which would be a
reaction to finite mindedness so
i don't know if more companies embraced
infinite mindedness but it became
clearer which ones had a shorter
lifespan